sponsored by step finance your go to d5
portfolio manager once
bitmex the og crypto derivatives
platform and the best place to buy your
bitcoin
hey guys and welcome back to the lehigh
fans show super excited to do this
podcast because i have my new studio as
you can see i have a new mic so if i'm
coming through nice and clear can you
let me know um so i'm really excited to
jump into all of this now before we kick
things off um this show is sponsored by
bitmex um so i want to do a quick shout
out to them so um bitmex is actually an
og crypto derivatives exchange and now
has a spot exchange for you to buy and
sell crypto especially in a bear market
you need a name that you can trust
bitmex sets the standard in reliability
performance and transparency and of
course it has proven itself through
multiple cycles stood the test of time
and that's really important with
everything that's going on right now and
everything that we're actually going to
talk about on the show um right now bimx
is actually celebrating the start of
bitmex spot with 1 million usd in prizes
pretty insane so to enter users just
need to trade the crypto equivalent of
250 us dollars users can enter up to um
25 times to win their share of the um
sweet steaks so it's pretty good one
lucky winner will even receive 500 000
usd in bit in bit max um in bitcoin from
bit max so pretty insane stuff there now
um in order to be part of this i've left
um a description and a link for you two
bit max in the description below so
definitely go check them out now this
show is also sponsored by our friends at
step finance and joining me today to
talk about all of this the market what
is going on whether d5 is over um is
george harp the co-founder of step
finance spring george on george welcome
to the show how you doing
hi leia it's great to be here good to be
back
yeah it's great to speak with you um
last time we spoke you were traveling
all over the world you were sort of
escaping the lockdowns um can we get um
a quick update where are you right now
yeah getting arrested or something oh
god hopefully not
yeah like so i've been i've been
traveling a bit as well still but i'm
trying to like chill out on that a bit
to be honest i'm kind of sick of it um
but uh no like i've been to asia
recently and um went over to vietnam for
a bit it was probably like the only
country that's really sort of opened up
in asia so it's like my first time back
in a couple of years um uh now in turkey
and sort of around europe as well so uh
so yeah just sort of doing my thing and
uh yeah you know i'd sort of i think
this for the next 12 months i might sort
of not be traveling as much because it
seems like all of this covered nonsense
is kind of ending so it's actually
getting a bit easier and you don't have
to like move every couple of months
yeah well you're in turkey um i remember
at one point turkey had those necessary
magical passes that you needed and those
injection passes so what's it like right
now i'm turkey i'm guessing it's a bit
better
oh yeah i mean there's none of that now
which is great um so so yeah i mean look
like i was walking down the street the
other day i saw like eight different uh
crypto shops that were just like
exchanging it for for cash for all these
different coins um i dare say they're
not regulated they probably don't have
licenses which is great um and yeah
they're just there doing business which
is what you want to see so so as a
country it gives like it's a thumbs up
from me uh but uh yeah
but turkey's pretty interesting because
um i think the didn't the president of
el salvador go to turkey recently or the
or the head of state from turkey went
over to el salvador um and also the
currency is not doing very well so
you know do you think they're likely to
would be the next country to adopt
bitcoin any other crypto what do you
think you know what i think it's
probably seeping into society here more
than other countries like there's just
random shops on the street that you can
oh you want to repair your iphone or
something cool you can pay the guy in
tether or bitcoin or something um and
you don't really see that everywhere
right like and i had another friend i
was talking to as well recently who was
saying very much the same sort of thing
so yeah i think as a society maybe
people have been pushed more towards
crypto because the lira is kind of a
nonsense currency that's been blown up
um and maybe that's kind of a catalyst
but
as i i think i've mentioned before i
think it's about one third of the
country has an exchange account um and
uh that's that's crazy numbers like that
that is really big um so yeah i actually
heard that number when i was talking to
one of the exchange operators here so um
yeah it's uh it's huge
that's crazy um i love i love i mean i i
was gonna say i'd love to see it but to
be clear i don't love to see the lyric
crashing i don't like to see any fiat
currency crashing unfortunately um but i
love to see the adoption and
particularly in countries that need it
um but let's kick things off um it's
been a pretty hectic
i'd say week we've seen crazy
liquidations um before we get into all
of that for those that don't know can
you tell us a little bit about step
finance
sure so step is a on a it's a portfolio
manager really it's an on-chain data
provider for the solana ecosystem and
and we're a place where you can you know
users can manage their portfolio across
all these different uh dapps uh so
there's about 50 different integrations
we're monitoring a lot of on-chain data
from all these dexes yield farms and
whatever it might be
and uh yeah we're just sort of that that
one place to go that gives you the
overview of everything so i guess you
know with all the market turmoil and all
these different things happening
recently uh we've been sort of sitting
at the at the the bird's eye view of of
really what's going on so yeah
yeah you have the information um let's
let's get into this what is your take um
you know
why
is the market crashing and you know
what's been going on and how long do you
think it's going to last
yeah we had a few catalysts didn't we
like it i i guess i don't know how long
it was was it two months ago that luna
was a thing it seems time has warped
it was i know when it was it was but
before i'd gone before i traveled so it
was like
maybe
april i think it was april may april i'm
going for may early may that's what i'm
going for early
something like that right so like a
couple of months ago things really
kicked off uh and we had luna this you
know supposed um
alternative blockchain that also had a
stable coin attached to it and ust
and the mechanism of which ust was
created was pretty much a ponzi scheme
they did have a lot of crypto backing it
they had like three billion in bitcoin
or whatever then they had 18 billion of
this ust coin issued so it doesn't
matter how much collateral you have like
if you have 18 billion owing on the
books and you only have 3 billion
backing it then there's nothing much you
can do but you know that unwinding i
think was really the first shock uh that
we saw in the market and then of course
yes there's the macro things going on
you got inflation and the fed and like
wars and all this kind of stuff um so i
mean that's not good and they're not
bullish things but um yeah i think
really it started with uh with luna and
then from that that kind of maybe
exposed some of the fragility in the
market of you know now we have like
celsius uh more recently having problems
and maybe going under nobody really
knows nobody's like transparent um and
that was like a centralized you know
lender
i'm pretty sure they had an app maybe
they had a website as well
yeah
yeah you could you know borrow coins and
that sort of thing um and then we had
three arrows capital as well who was one
of the very large funds in the ecosystem
a lot of people looked up to them uh and
uh they also seem like they've gone
under nobody quite knows again being
very silent not really talking to
partners
billions of dollars at stake seems like
there was a lot of leverage in the
ecosystem they borrowed a lot of money
didn't pay it back other people you know
are saying where's my money and it's not
there so yeah look i think it's been a
crazy time and all of that um has
probably resulted in a lot of cell
pressure on the market right so you know
we in the celsius instance uh in in that
case like i think there was there was
one on-chain contract uh which you could
monitor a lot of people looking at the
ether scan uh you know transaction for
that it was like 148 million uh of
ethereum i think was was locked up uh in
that contract and it had a specific
liquidation price so i think we we very
nearly escaped liquidation on that the
the price was was very uh very close but
um you know i think that's a good
example of on-chain data right is
usually in a financial market we don't
really have an idea of what people's
individual liquidation prices are what's
the real story going on behind the
scenes whereas at least if everything's
on chain you can just like look at the
actual blockchain to see what's going on
uh is the money there or not uh are
these loans being paid back or not and
that's been i think a a plus point of
the last couple of weeks is we can at
least see what's going on and people can
sort of monitor it in real time which is
pretty cool
yeah but i think that not everyone
understands that because you know on
chain data can be super daunting um you
know people not you know a lot of people
do own crypto but doesn't mean they
understand the on-chain data side of
things so how can people um essentially
start measuring those on-chain metrics
what should they be looking for um what
you know how where do they go basically
to start
yeah so i mean fundamentally these are
kind of complex things right you know
when we're talking about collateralizing
a loan in a you know some sort of coin
to then borrow a stable coin to then
lend it to someone else for an interest
rate like
they're not simple concepts so i think
firstly like
definitely reading up on these things
and how they work and the mechanisms
involved that's like step number one
right do your own research it's always
step number one um but after that uh
look there's a lot of different
platforms right so uh in the case that i
mentioned before you know that was a
specific uh maker dow vault uh which is
a a essentially people lock up ethereum
on the ethereum blockchain and then they
mint a stablecoin against that called
die
and you can see these these transactions
happening and and in this case a lot of
people are looking at etherscan for a
lot of that information um in the case
of step uh on solana as well uh you know
we
you can monitor funding rates across a
lot of the different blockchains and
different pool values and and wallets
you can look at what exposure wallets
have to how much they're borrowing how
much uh you know they have in collateral
and what their collateral rates are so
um yeah look i think there's a lot of
tools out there uh nansen another great
example uh dune another great example
glass node these are all sort of giving
you these these insights to look at
these contracts but that's only really
half the problem right the other half of
the problem is to understand what on
earth all these things actually mean um
so i think you need a bit of both right
having the tools is great but also you
sort of need to know what to look for at
the same time
yeah but you you touched on this but i
do want to get more detail on this
because liquidations are um not what we
want um you know especially you don't
want to have your funds frozen and you
can't withdraw them so i think that
moving forward people will need to
understand the on-chain data be able to
interpret it um and know which places to
stay away from so in terms of you know
luna celsius um 3ac everything that you
mentioned what were people looking at on
chain to get the most accurate
information about what's going on
yeah so
there's a couple like so the vault was
one you know that was that was apple
funding rates are another one so with
luna what we saw was when it was stuck
ust was starting to d peg right ust was
a dollar it was their stable coin and
then it started to go to like 98 cents
or 97 cents or something like that and a
lot of people were watching uh some of
the the lunar explorers to see how much
lunar is being burned and redeemed
because how it worked was that
essentially you burned luna to create
the stable coin and then if you wanted
to unwind your stable coin then it
created luna so it's kind of like cool
it's great if everyone just burns luna
right and then the price of luna goes up
everyone's happy but when the reverse
happens it's kind of a cascade right so
you know a lot of people are looking at
some of these explorers
and and we're seeing like a lot more
coins being minted and that created a
lot of inflated supply which turned up
in the futures markets funding rates so
if you went on to some of the futures
exchanges like you know the binance is
the world ftx maybe uh bitmex also has a
lunar market i don't know if they did um
but you could see it in the in the
perpetual futures right in one case uh
we could see on step that the funding
rate i aka the price it costs for you to
short luna it was something like 88 000
or 800 000 per year um so that's pretty
pricey right if you're going to short
that currency you're paying a lot of
money to short it um but that really
sort of shows you the sentiment right so
given that information
um of what the markets are actually
doing and what people are doing with
their money then maybe you can make the
conclusion like hey this peg is not
gonna hold this like 98 cent thing it's
probably going to go to zero and that's
exactly what happened uh and uh and we
saw it sort of you know fall quite a bit
from there um we people also monitoring
the the movements as well in in some of
the wallets on nansen uh from the three
billion treasury which was meant to be
backing it we saw that that went to
binance and then sort of went into a
black hole after that and the assumption
was that all the bitcoin was sold to try
and you know back up this thing and of
course that wasn't good because that was
bad for bitcoin that's a lot of sales
and then if bitcoin goes down everything
else comes down as well um so you know i
think that's kind of what creates these
cascades and and uh you know if
something goes down a lot a lot of
people get liquidated that makes it go
down more and you get this like force
feedback loop which is uh quite
destructive
yeah really destructive um and so for
that reason i want to get into d5 um i
have titled this show is defy over is
defy dead um because you know
we often hear people say when the bear
market comes nothing but bitcoin will
survive um you know i think that is um
an exaggeration but what i think was
interesting for me personally this week
um
was the disruption on the solana network
and i know obviously step is sort of
part of that ecosystem so and before we
get into solana can you sort of give us
some background and an overview of what
actually happened the network was on it
was off the price crashed what happened
so it wasn't it actually the solana
network's been great uh it's been very
fast it's the latest update what the
problem was was that there was one
individual application uh called soul
land and they were a lender and they had
one uh uh so essentially you put your uh
sole or usdc or you know wrapped bitcoin
or something into their lending protocol
and then you can borrow other coins
against it um so that's all well and
good but you can get liquidated if the
value of your collateral falls and
that's exactly what was happening right
with this market turmoil the price of
seoul was going down and this particular
whale was something like you know 70 of
of their order book um so you know very
big position and
they had a sort of i guess an emergency
internal meeting um they have a
governance token as well so this was all
out in the open so that's i guess
another thing to keep in mind is some of
these default protocols they have these
governance tokens right and and what
does that mean well it means that people
get to vote on stuff what do they get to
vote on
i mean it's sort of who knows is the
first answer to that um that the second
answer is like well like people can
propose their own
uh you know things to vote on and if
enough people vote on it but how it
worked out with this particular scenario
was that this well had i think it was
130 million of collateral in this
lending protocol and they were borrowing
a hundred million worth their
thereabouts in stable coins and uh and
the problem was if that 130 million went
down
below 100 then you know that could cause
contagion for the rest of protocol and
everyone loses money kind of thing um so
they had a vote
and uh of what to do and one of the
proposals was to take control of the
wales account
and to be able to sell that balance
right and how much did you need to to do
this vote well you needed 700k
so i think a lot of people quite rightly
brought the point of like hold on i only
need 700k to vote on what to do with 130
million like that's a pretty crazy
situation that's the first thing
secondly like what we're voting to take
someone's money that's also pretty crazy
like why
that that's against a lot of ethos right
of decentralization so um they had a
second vote and the second vote annulled
the first vote uh and uh then i think
there's been a third vote uh as well
yeah but luckily you know the price of
seoul's gone up so that's no longer a
imminent risk
um so yeah like on the first instance
like look this is just one particular uh
i guess you call it app uh on the solana
blockchain there's lots of apps on lots
of blockchains um
but i guess maybe one positive to bring
out of this is at least it was all out
in the open it wasn't like celsius where
it was like oh i don't know what's
happening
is the money going to be there tomorrow
who knows at least we all knew where we
stood like we could see the the position
like you could look at the wallet in
step you could go well okay they don't
have that the price goes down too much
more like that money's gonna be poof
like disappear
yeah i mean i think having it all out on
the open is really important
transparency is obviously key um
particularly um in this space
particularly comes to finance as well
but my issue was the fact that they had
the ability to vote to take control of
somebody's money and i think i don't
really i
my concerns about that aren't really
eased by the fact that they were able to
have another vote
um
i for me i'm just like wow like this is
bad
um
because if that's possible what else is
possible
um
you know and as somebody who i know
you're would you regard yourself as a
freedom maximalist is that sort of how
you say yeah
yeah so somebody who's a freedom maxi a
bit like myself um
how how does that sit okay with you
well everyone's able to make their own
apps and everyone's able to make their
own configurations of those apps maybe i
make a app where i say that i'm a
communist dictator and and all of the
money has to go to george and yeah
nobody has any rights as long as there's
a free market to do that i great like
100 percent for it and if people want to
invest in that thing fantastic um but uh
but yeah ultimately i think
if the first thing was yes at least it
was all transparent the second thing was
that luckily it didn't go through um but
uh yeah it does bring up some questions
right yeah and i think you know the
team's probably learned from that
i really like the soul end team i think
they do a great job um but yeah i think
maybe this this vote and this proposal
was maybe a misstep um but uh but to be
honest like is it really that different
to a centralized exchange when they can
just lock your account because you
didn't do no
like it's no different right so no it's
no different but no i'm with you it's no
different but defy is defy decentralized
finance it prides itself on being
sovereign and you know only you control
your assets like sort of reminds me of
the whole issue about metamask we're
like oh well maybe you know
it's not that safe which is why
i always say i feel like every bear
market more bitcoin maxies are born
[Music]
well i'd maybe maybe that's the case i i
think certainly bear markets like expose
vulnerabilities and things that are
built up over a bull market and i think
you saw that with 3ac whereby in a bull
market wow with like the best fun in the
world we're so rich got all this money
it's pumping woohoo like let's buy a
super yacht um but then as soon as
things don't go their way uh things
implode so it kind of like it exposes
maybe some of the underlying cracks and
and that's good for the whole ecosystem
in general we see that every single time
there's always blow ups uh and people
get better you know from the most part
uh for that so uh so yeah i think it's
about if people do their research enough
and sort of understand these mechanisms
um then you can at least try and tread
the waters and be able to see you know
what's what's a good idea what's not a
good idea and be able to maybe evaluate
that and and you know value the risk uh
involved in some of these different
things
so where would you say we're at right
now with the markets um
yeah i'm gonna leave the question very
open-ended and broad okay
yeah uh well a i don't know nobody knows
i think is the answer all i can say is
look i've been in this thing for over a
decade i've seen this kind of stuff
happen many times before all these
different blow ups um peak fear everyone
thinking it's going to zero tomorrow uh
it's not going to zero um and uh there
will be
a new blooming of a bull market at some
stage don't know when that'll be um you
know don't know what the catalyst for
that will be but it's always something
different you know history it doesn't
repeat itself but it often rhymes so i
think that thing it's it's great isn't
it right and it's true um it's often a
little bit different each time you know
there's there's some similar concepts
that we can take from it but you know
it's uh it's a little bit different so i
think we probably have to wait for a lot
of this leverage to to unwind there's
still like a lot of these big funds
which built up that have these over
collateralized under collateralized
positions that owe a lot of money um and
and i'm sort of hearing as well from
some of my friends you know that are
doing funding rounds and stuff vcs
aren't as willing to to you know go and
uh fund these things as they once were
so
i'm sure that's a bit of an indicator
for sentiment uh
like we'll sort of see where things go
it's interesting because um you know we
often say that these um four-year cycles
are driven by the bitcoin halving and so
we tend to start predicting things and
based on that on that metric and it's
been proven right um so far however
people like willy woo who also you know
look at the on-chain data um
have started to say that because of all
the smart money that's come into the
space
um these four-year cycles are now sort
of done and finished um what's your take
what's smart money
i guess like um you know
like the micro strategies and like major
institutions institutional money that's
the thing if they were smart they would
have been in 12 years ago
so that's that's the thing so people go
oh the smart money i think it's the dumb
money right so it's like
that's how i see it is you're the smart
money george you go in 10 years ago yeah
well it's like
i'd pick any time frame that's like not
today like that's that's smart money
so like yes look i think institutions
coming in has probably been a thing
which has happened this bull cycle which
everyone like probably drove a lot of
the hype and you know everything number
go up and everyone's happy um but it's
also a double-edged sword right because
that also means that we're very
correlated to stocks uh which we are
it's like literally
the correlation chart is like exactly
the same
so that's bad because that means that
these institutions now have crypto on
their balance sheet and then oh the
stock market's going down i need to
cover my positions i'll sell some crypto
because i have a small uh you know piece
there and i don't really you know care
about it so
i'm going to sell that first and then
that makes crypto you know worse off for
it so i think fundamentally like you
need people and i always say this like
the the primary reason to get into
crypto is like the ideological philos
philosophical reasons for it um you know
that that's sort of the most important
thing in my mind and there will be
people that come and go there will be
traders that appear on twitter that like
tell you looking at the charts and the
stars where they think the number and
the line will go um but but these are
sort of you know passing through uh you
know these people are sort of passing
through so i think the the people that
have often had the best returns have
been the ones that have thought of
themselves as investors rather than
traders so i think that's how people
should consider themselves is like you
know why why do you think that this is
the future of the financial world um why
do you think it's good for people to to
have bitcoin or other cryptocurrencies
um if if those reasons are sound and
that plays out great and i think it's
either going to be like bitcoin's either
going to be zero dollars or a million
dollars um it's still in that anything
in between that is like just an
undecided state um we're and the the
longer that we're not zero the more
likely a million is so uh so yeah
there you go how to hear first on the
latest
show i love that i love a good
prediction um but you didn't fully
answer the question for your cycles are
they over um i assume they must be if
all this institutional money's coming in
and it's
therefore not this uncorrelated asset
yeah four year cycles i don't think we
need to put a timeline on it that's what
i would say i i think
the
the
the macro is so messed up in the world
right now like america's how much in
debt like on the books 30 trillion or
something trillions yeah yeah uh like
unfunded liabilities 300 trillion um
like it brings in like trillions less in
tax revenue than it can to actually go
and pay the bills so like fundamentally
the us dollar the linchpin of the entire
economy is screwed like long-term
doesn't matter if it's a bull market
spare market you know the stock market
go up or down like fundamentally you
look at it on a long scale doesn't work
can never be paid back debt must be
printed in order to to keep going um so
uh so yeah i i think in the long term
like things will will go up the question
is like is that a four year cycle i
don't know i i think things will be much
faster now i think
the the leverage in the ecosystem and
all of the money printing that's
happened after covert has just made
things like happen way quicker so you
might slosh all one way and then slosh
all the other way so we might be down 80
today and then we'll be up like 200
percent tomorrow um like
that i think that yeah quicker cycles is
is probably the way to go so probably
not four years um yeah maybe quicker and
does that align with the bitcoin halving
and i mean yes it could be coincidental
though i think um
and uh yeah like if you look at the
the the coins which a bitcoin halving
like reduces from uh new supply like
it's actually not that much like the
exchanges pick any market on finance and
it will probably do more daily volume
than the entire you know halving bitcoin
of like the last month or so so yeah
it's uh it's something tbd
yeah and speaking of um the whole thing
is um speeding up um that 2030 agenda
where you'll owe nothing and be happy i
think that's speeding up to 2025 i think
so
it's you know it's just a catalyst and
actually i think somebody posted today
an article from forbes from 2016 which
actually shows them talking about this
2030 agenda we've only just become more
aware and awake to it because of
everything that's just happened um
so
yeah it's it's it's speeding up that's
for sure um
you get to read i know i know exactly
that poor guy as well who's become the
face of the great
literally literally that poor guy he
probably all he wanted to do was be a
model or something and then he ended up
being becoming
a great reset
oh that's funny um he's probably like
not even vaccinated he's probably just
like really adding all this stuff but
there you go um but we were talking
about like you know narratives and
adoption and things like that um you
know bitcoin's always whole always held
that um
that narrative as um
as a hedge against inflation
um and that's sort of the reason why
people tend to flock to um to bitcoin um
so what do you think is going to be that
reason i was thinking
it's everything that you mentioned it's
all the rubbish that's gone on you know
canada freezing accounts and all this
stuff which will wake people up what's
your take
yeah uh
so the question is like what's the
catalyst or bitcoin you know where does
it sit in
[Music]
yeah
yeah because like right now um you know
we're seeing a 40-year highs when it
comes to inflation bitcoin isn't really
acting as that hedge against inflation
in the short term um so people aren't
necessarily flocking to bitcoin as a
hedge right now um so what would make
them flock to bitcoin um in the near
future yeah it's a good question like so
the whole hedge against inflation thing
again it kind of depends on your
perspective right like
you could go and look at the chart and
you can say well you know for the
monthly we're down for the yearly like
maybe we're down but actually after two
years we're up like 200 and after four
years we're up like yeah 500 or whatever
the number is so i guess you know the
whole hedge against inflation thing like
does that mean that has to always go
like one line straight up uh all the
time i don't think anyone expects that
right so it's kind of like what time
frame are you assuming that this is
gonna happen and and what are the
reasons that people might want to to
hold crypto i think it's probably
getting closer to people like so for
example um a lot of i've had to do a lot
of like international wires recently and
it's most painful hateful purpose
horrendous
it's and like money just disappears and
nobody knows why and then it's like oh
it'll bounce back in 30 days uh oh and
that's like a normal acceptable thing
apparently um and there's an
intermediary bank involved for some
reason and then you have to pay their
money but you don't really know at the
start of the transaction how bad it is
and yeah like you know just trying to
get like bank accounts reactivated and
these sorts of things like the whole
system is just completely terrible um
and i've done a few payments recently
where i've just paid people in tether um
and i was tweeting about that recently
as well where it was just so much easier
like what's your address here's my
address and i just paid them done they
don't have to think about anything and
like it's everything's provable like i
can give you the the transaction link um
so i think like we're definitely the
more broken the system is it's actually
better so i think things need to get
worse before they get better um and i
i'm actually on the one hand yes things
getting worse for people is bad but on
the other hand it's like i think it's
actually for the better in the long run
and people will be better off in the
long run if things get worse so you know
if the local banking system doesn't work
and everyone switches to crypto because
it doesn't work or the local currency uh
you know gets wrecked in a whole big
blow up somewhere like the 1998
financial crisis
um yeah maybe that's a catalyst for
people to to actually go and switch i
think that's probably looking more and
more likely by the day uh it's just a
question of like where is it actually
gonna flare up first and uh yeah i think
like international payments is certainly
one area that should like be displaced
by crypto like so
easily
yeah i totally agree with you um it's
funny that you mentioned that because
i've actually also been doing a
ridiculous amount of international
payments recently and they're
disappearing like i've had a big payment
that should have arrived which hasn't
arrived like they're it's actually
insane three to five business days it's
been a month like can we can we get some
customer service
um
it's actually insane because obviously
i'm british and you know in in the uk
doing payments from one person to
another is super easy
um it's free faster payments is fine um
but as i expand and i i move around the
world
it's
actually horrendous
yeah why are you okay with this like why
is there not riots in the streets i
don't know because this should affect
everyone like in some really bad some
way yeah
i i don't really know i also think it's
because like you know what it is it's
because
we're moving towards a global world
aren't we
so like initially
okay tech is developing but we would we
would stay within our own countries
whereas now borders are of course we
have we have portal control but borders
are are dropping the world is getting
smaller you know with all this
technology and we're all working remote
and internationally and everybody's sort
of going all over the world um and so i
think as you know tech continues to
evolve and so the world becomes smaller
perhaps then it will shed a light on it
and more people will realize how broken
it is what do you think
yeah i mean
often i've also found that the best
systems to move money have also been the
systems that have worked for thousands
of years so the the oldest transfer
system in the world is called
and it's basically you know a guy who
knows a guy and then money moves and
it's like you know you pay someone and
then they pay someone else locally
because the local systems often work
okay like the domestic banking in uk
it's fast and whatever but whenever you
need to like convert between these
different systems it's just complete
mayhem um so yeah like i've i've seen a
lot of that like in a previous life in
the remittances world i think the number
was that there's there's something like
2 000 individual payment systems in the
world
and like that means like wire being one
system uh and then like swift and faster
payments and whatever else and local
countries and apps and all this sort of
2000 different systems so like that's
the fundamental problem of why things
are so broken it's like literally
nothing's interruptable interoperable
nothing really works everyone has their
own currencies and their own agendas and
their own rules um so like really you
need like a level playing field right
and that's what i think crypto is and
and maybe that's bitcoin um
and that is like the one unit of account
that you can just sort of move
everywhere and it's like really simple
to do and if everyone agrees on that
then life becomes way better and
economic growth you know goes very well
and people are able to do much more
stuff in the economy like if you have to
spend days trying to pay someone that's
such a waste and i often think like and
then there's people employed to like do
these jobs as well and i i often think
like their job is based on
an incompetent system being terrible
and that's that's such a waste of like
productivity in the economy like you
have all these people just earning money
for doing like nonsense things um there
was a very good book called [ __ ]
jobs uh which uh everyone should go and
read um but uh yeah it sort of sheds a
light a little bit on
some of these things that we take for
granted every day maybe they don't need
to exist uh maybe they can be automated
uh and uh yeah you know payments is a
good example of that
well
i have two questions that i want to ask
you um
the first one is with everything that's
going on in the world right now um you
know in terms of um
stock market
um wars
um supply chain issues
um you know just all this broken
brokenness um
do you do you think that it's it's
destruction by design um or do you think
we simply just have incompetent people
um in charge
yeah you know there's a good saying
don't ascribe uh negligence to what can
be described by incompetence
and i think it's
i think it is uh uh you know
incompetence i think it's like it's not
a a plan per se that i would say or you
know if there's like overlords that are
moving pieces on a chessboard you don't
believe in the overlords i mean there
are people who want power absolutely
yeah um and you know these are horrible
people um i don't want bill gates
putting a microchip in me um but you
know would you like elon musk
uh
no i don't want anybody checking sorry
to check yeah even if they long come
that was a great idea um
but um yeah look i i so they probably
are like a lot of baddies out there um
but often like how do they impose their
will upon
people everywhere it's it's quite
difficult um so
like yeah there might be some common
threads there uh but i think there is a
lot of dysfunction in the world and
there's a lot of like you know muppets
in high positions and often these
muppets just are prone to making poor
decisions we see this all throughout
history there's emperors and rulers who
are just incompetent and are like total
fools and that's how they're remembered
for thousands of years later it's no
different today um so like we we have a
lot of those people around the world
right now and uh yeah i think that's the
main problem and i think the solution to
the problem is not trying to like find
better ways to do things it's to make
the rulers
and uh and make them less important to
your daily life so if they can't impact
your life that's the ultimate thing like
i wish like the president of a country
was such a useless position they
couldn't decide anything for anyone's
life you know they couldn't lock you in
your home or they couldn't you know take
take away your money and your bank
account or close it or freeze it or
whatever um i think if i if we had you
know more of more of that of uh you know
taking away a lot of that power and just
ascribing by a rule book um i think the
world would be a better place so um so
yeah that that's what i hope we can get
to one day is to reduce the power of
these rulers and maybe the best way to
do that is to take the money away from
them via
via crypto so i want to push on that
[ __ ] because of what we spoke about
earlier um you know with solend and
things like that um
i still feel um and i'd like you to
maybe convince me otherwise i don't know
it's up to you um
i still feel um that bitcoin is sort of
the only
um or one or not the only like one of
the safest bets just given there is no
um just given the decentralization and
and everything that we saw that happened
with solend um
you know where they could actually vote
um and if you didn't have i think you
said seven hundred thousand dollars um
you didn't get a vote um
so yeah what do you think uh like
bitcoin's been through many different
crises in its history as well um
back in 2010 there was i think that was
the one where there was like 184 billion
bitcoin bug
and they had satoshi had to roll back
the chain so there was a chain reorg
at that point and that was about one
year into bitcoin or was that 2010 yeah
so it would have been about a year and a
bit into bitcoin's history um 2013 uh i
think there was another incident then
that was another i think rollback with a
client or something like that i think it
was like the bitcoin core client 0.7 to
0.8 or something like that so again that
was like a majority hash rate decision
literally one person doing that the time
was btc guild um and then i've i've been
around where gigahash dot io had 51 hash
power for like two weeks
so it was through the goodness of their
hearts that they didn't double spend
transactions uh and we're all here today
to talk about how wonderful bitcoin is
but
that that's a couple of years into
bitcoin's existence right so okay let's
look at these other chains how old are
they usually a couple years and they
have these problems okay so they're on
exactly the same trajectory as bitcoin
so where will they be in 13 years um
probably a lot better situation i would
hope um so i would say that look bitcoin
isn't a shining beacon um there have
been problems in the past and we should
be real with that that they are real
things that have happened um and
okay given that information like what to
do now like yes bitcoins in a really
good situation right now uh you know
there's maybe a couple of ways you can
measure like decentralization people
throw around that word a lot right oh
decentralize this where to centralize
that um i kind of don't like it anymore
like it because it doesn't mean anything
like people don't really know what they
what they mean when they say it um there
is one way to to measure
decentralization it's the nakamoto
coefficient i think it's called uh it's
a measure of like how many people need
to collude
to
essentially do something bad in the
network so like basically you want you
want the maximum number of people
necessary so you want the coefficient
really high
because that means that it's very
unlikely that tens of thousands are out
people around the world that all don't
know each other and all have competing
economic interests are gonna like all
screw each other at the same time to
their own you know detriment um yeah so
but there's some blockchains that you
know they might just have one person who
can who can do it so look bitcoin ranks
highly there um celina actually ranks
very highly ethereum ranks very highly
there um there is no on off button for
all of these other alt chains as much as
bitcoin maxis would like to tell you um
zlana has 1700 validators um none of
them have the off button uh ethereum has
proof of work at the moment it'll be
going to proof of stake soon
see how that goes i guess but proof of
work's been pretty solid for ethereum so
far having said that ethereum came out
of a fork we're currently using forked
ethereum if we all cared about
decentralization we'd be using ethereum
classic um because that was pre-dow hack
that's why ethereum forked in the first
place because vitalik didn't like people
losing money
so again like all of these different
systems
uh like they they have each had crises
in in their lifetimes and um some of
them i think now you you can't just say
hey i'm gonna launch a blockchain uh see
you in 10 years when everything's all
good it's like no no you have to speed
run the last decade for these things and
try and learn from all these mistakes
and then just like never make a mistake
ever i think that's pretty unrealistic
um so yeah i don't know if i can
convince you but i would just say like
you know there lots of things have
happened to lots of chains including
bitcoin so we should just keep an open
mind
yeah no i appreciate that i think it's
good times conversations um lots to um
continue to learn um so given we are in
this um dreary crypto winter
dreary bear market what would your
advice be to people right now
to the dreariness um well yeah how do
you survive a bear market what should
they be doing
i think again it goes back to like
learning the fundamentals of things um
so this is a good time to research
because often in a a bull market you get
all flashing lights and explosions
everywhere hey this coin's making a
billion percent you're going to get rich
tomorrow blah blah blah
that's often what people see uh when you
know bull markets happen and when that's
not the case people maybe find
themselves a little bit lost um but i
think like if you think that
cryptocurrency is going to be a force
for good like look into these d5
protocols what's the lender like can i
get a loan by clicking a few buttons you
know with a smart contract and is that
better than a bank why is it better than
a bank um is it easier than a bank um
can i go and send money and move
payments overseas without having to talk
to a bunch of muppets between 9 00 a.m
and 5 p.m every day um like you know all
these things right so it's i i would say
like that's all you can really do in a
bear mark in a bear market right it's
like focus on the education focus on
finding like either good projects or
good people that you like and it's not
really investment advice even if you
don't have any money to invest i think
that it's just interesting like even if
you're interested in freedom um and like
what do these people have to say what's
their philosophy why are they doing
things
if they're doing things to get rich it's
probably not the not the people to
follow um but yeah if there is some sort
of meaning behind it then great they're
they're sort of the people to to look
out for
yeah i think that's a really good
last sort of final note um you know be
aware of the narratives around certain
projects um
and companies and people um that's
really really important um so george
what um
where can people follow you um you know
how can they find out more about step
give us the the full overview
yeah uh i'm on twitter at george
underscore harrop uh or step finance on
twitter as well just uh just find us uh
we've got a discord as well so yeah
always open to hear from new people
actually you know one thing as well that
happens in in uh in sort of bull markets
or bear markets is we're seeing just a
lot of new people who are totally brand
new to crypto they have no prior
experience of any of this kind of stuff
so actually a lot of our customers like
maybe even the majority over 50
are in that category they have no prior
experience with other stuff so you know
that's that's good that's um you know
there's new people uh getting interested
in what's happening in this ecosystem
and learning and um yeah you know come
and join and we're happy to help educate
amazing guys go follow george um he has
um a lot of incredible commentary
particularly on things that are going on
in the world right now um freedom maxi
which i think is super important um we
need more people like that and yeah
definitely go check out step finance um
while you're there george thank you so
much it's been such a pleasure catching
up with you
thank you so much for having me it's
been a pleasure absolutely and guys
please don't forget if you are watching
on youtube to hit the subscribe button
hit the like button so you never miss a
video we'll see you all next week malaya
high or pancho